i call him my boyfriend and he calls me
his girlfriend
julie fox called kanye west her
boyfriend just last week but now a
source tells e.t the two are no longer
together you kind of like connect the
dots the uncut gemstar and the rapper
are going their separate ways after
dating a little over a month julia
seemingly addressed the split in a now
deleted post to her instagram story
reportedly telling her followers she and
kanye are on good terms adding she still
has love for kanye but she wasn't in
love with him and as far as claims she's
upset by the split julia posted this
message to her ig story crying where
i need you to run right back baby
more specifically
[Music]
the breakup comes on the brink of the
grammy winner's public attempts to win
back his estranged wife kim kardashian
yay went on a posting spree on instagram
over the weekend in one pleat he shared
a pic of kim and her current bow pete
davidson with a caption that reads in
part i have faith that we'll be back
together
and earlier this month a source
explained to et why kanye is lashing out
on social media he misses his kids and
he wants what is best for his family
everything he has been doing has been
coming from a place of feeling deeply
hurt and detached from the people he
loves the most in the world this is his
way of fighting to get his family back
just do something for my heart
yay never stopped trying to publicly win
back kim while with julia something she
addressed on alex cooper's call her
daddy podcast
i'm sure there's still some sort of
residual feelings and it's like it's
normal it's human you know but
i also like
know that he's with me now so
and that's all that matters
at the time an e.t source says the
actress wasn't worried about kanye and
kim getting back together she's just
enjoying the ride and taking it all in
but fans started speculating the pair
was no more when yay stepped out with
cheney jones a model who bears a
striking resemblance to kim you just
gotta roll with it our source adds that
despite the split kanye and julia remain
good friends and collaborators and it
seems now the two are putting full focus
on their family
[Music]
that's the 31 year old spending some
quality play time with her one year old
son
[Music]
as for kanye
kanye how are you
how are you doing today oh what up baby
how you been
good you with the babies today enjoy
enjoy
the jesus walks rapper took his eldest
kids north and saint to the super bowl
on sunday
oh we got good seats dorothy
the kids even snagged themselves a
special souvenir from l.a rams player
odell beckham jr while sitting in the
stairs
[Applause]
[Music]